uh let me ask you the important question
about size
so uh the size matter in terms of neural
networks uh with how good the system
performs uh so gpt3 3.5 had 175 billion
I heard GPT 4 at 100 trillion 100
trillion can I speak to this
do you know that Meme yeah the big
purple circle you know where it
originally I don't do I'd be curious to
hear it's the presentation I gave no way
yeah uh journalists just took a snapshot
huh
now I learned from this
it's right when gpt3 was released I gave
uh this on YouTube a gay description of
what it is
and I spoke to the limitations of the
parameters like where it's going and I
talked about the human brain and how
many parameters it has synapses and so
on
and
um perhaps like an idiot perhaps not I
said like gpt4 like the next as it
progresses what I should have said is
gptn or something I can't believe that
this came from you that is but people
should go to it it's totally taken out
of context they didn't reference
anything they took it this is what gpt4
is going to be and I feel horrible about
it you know it doesn't it I don't think
it matters in any serious way I mean
it's not good because uh again size is
not everything but also people just take
uh a lot of these kinds of discussions
out of context
uh but it is interesting to come I mean
that's what I was trying to do to come
to compare in different ways
uh the difference between the human
brain and the neural network and this
thing is getting so impressive this is
like in some sense
someone said to me this morning actually
and I was like oh this might be right
this is the most complex software object
Humanity has yet produced
and it will be trivial in a couple of
decades right it'll be like kind of
anyone can do it whatever
um but yeah the amount of complexity
relative to anything we've done so far
that goes into producing this one set of
numbers
it's quite something
yeah complexity including the entirety
the history of human civilization that
built up all the different advancements
to technology that build up all the
content the data that was the GPT was
trained on that is on the internet that
it's the compression of all of humanity
of all the maybe not the experience all
of the text output that Humanity
produces yeah just somewhat different
it's a good question how much if all you
have is the internet data
how much can you reconstruct the magic
of what it means to be human
I think we'd be surprised how much you
can reconstruct
but you probably need a more uh better
and better and better models but on that
topic how much does size matter by like
number of parameters number of
parameters
I think people got caught up in the
parameter count race in the same way
they got caught up in the gigahertz race
of processors and like the you know 90s
and 2000s or whatever
you I think probably have no idea how
many gigahertz the processor on your
phone is
but what you care about is what the
thing can do for you and there's you
know different ways to accomplish that
you can bump up the clock speed
sometimes that causes other problems
sometimes it's not the best way to get
gains
um
but I think what matters is getting the
best performance
and
you know we I think one thing that works
well about open AI
is we're pretty truth seeking in just
doing whatever is going to make the best
performance whether or not it's the most
elegant solution so I think like
llms are sort of hated result in parts
of the field everybody wanted to come up
with a more elegant way to get to
generalized intelligence
and we have been willing to just keep
doing what works and looks like it'll
keep working
so I've
spoken with no Chomsky who's been kind
of um one of the many people that are
critical of large language models being
able to achieve general intelligence
right and so it's an interesting
question that they've been able to
achieve so much incredible stuff do you
think it's possible that large language
models really is the way we we build AGI
I think it's part of the way I think we
need other super important things
this is philosophizing a little bit like
what what kind of components do you
think
in a technical sense or a poetic sense
doesn't need to have a body that it can
experience the world directly
I don't think it needs that
but I wouldn't I wouldn't say any of
this stuff with certainty like we're
deep into the unknown here for me
A system that cannot go significantly
add to the sum total of scientific
knowledge we have access to kind of
discover invent whatever you want to
call it new fundamental science
is not a super intelligence
and
to do that really well I think we will
need to expand on the GPT Paradigm in
pretty important ways that we're still
missing ideas for
but I don't know what those ideas are
we're trying to find them I could argue
sort of the opposite point that you
could have deep big scientific
breakthroughs with just the data that
GPT is trained on it's like
like if you prompted correctly look if
an oracle told me far from the future
that gpt10 turned out to be a true AGI
somehow maybe just some very small new
ideas
I would be like okay I can believe that
not what I would have expected sitting
here would have said a new big idea but
I can believe that
this prompting chain
if you extend it very far
and and then increase at scale the
number of those interactions like what
kind of these things start getting
integrated into human society and starts
building on top of each other I mean
like I don't think we understand what
that looks like like you said it's been
six days the thing that I am so excited
about with this is not that it's a
system that kind of goes off and does
its own thing but that it's this tool
that humans are using in this feedback
loop
helpful for us for a bunch of reasons we
get to you know learn more about
trajectories through multiple iterations
but
I am excited about a world where AI is
an extension of human will and a
amplifier of our abilities and this like
you know most useful tool yet created
and that is certainly how people are
using it
and I mean just like look at Twitter
like the the results are amazing
people's like self-reported happiness
with getting to work with this are great
so yeah like maybe we never build AGI
but we just make humans super great
still a huge win
yeah I said I'm part of those people
like the the amount
I derive a lot of Happiness from
programming together with GPT
uh part of it is a little bit of Terror
of can you say more about that
there's a meme I saw today that
everybody's freaking out about sort of
GPT taking programmer jobs no it's uh
the the the reality is just it's going
to be taking like if it's going to take
your job it means you're a shitty
programmer there's some truth to that
maybe there's some human element that's
really fundamental to the creative act
to the active genius that is in great
design that is of all the programming
and maybe I'm just really impressed by
the all the boilerplate
but that I don't see as boilerplate but
it's actually pretty boilerplate yeah it
may be that you create like you know in
a day of programming you have one really
important idea yeah
and that's the content which is that's
the contribution and there may be like I
I think we're gonna find
so I suspect that is happening with
great programmers and that gpt-like
models are far away from that one thing
even though they're going to automate a
lot of other programming
but again most programmers have some
sense of
you know anxiety about what the future
is going to look like but mostly they're
like this is amazing I am 10 times more
productive don't ever take this away
from me there's not a lot of people that
use it and say like turn this off you
know
yeah so I think uh so to speak to the
psychology of Terror is more like
this is awesome this is too awesome yeah
there is a little bit of coffee tastes
too good
you know when Casper I've lost to deep
blue somebody said
and maybe it was him that like chess is
over now if an AI can beat a human at
chess then no one's going to bother to
keep playing right because like what's
the purpose of us or whatever that was
30 years ago 25 years ago something like
that
I believe that chess has never been more
popular than it is right now
and
people keep wanting to play and wanting
to watch and by the way we don't watch
two AIS play each other
which would be a far better game in some
sense than whatever else but that's
that's not what we choose to do like we
are somehow much more interested in what
humans do in this sense and whether or
not Magnus loses to that kid then what
happens when two much much better AIS
Play Each Other Well actually when two
AIS play each other it's not a better
game by our definition of but because we
just can't understand it no I think I
think they just draw each other I think
the human flaws and this might apply
across the Spectrum here with AIS will
make life way better
but we'll still want drama we will
that's for sure still want imperfection
and flaws and AI will not have as much
of that look I mean I hate to sound like
utopic Tech bro here but if you'll
excuse me for three seconds like the the
the level of
the increase in quality of life that AI
can deliver is extraordinary
we can make the world amazing and we can
make people's lives amazing we can cure
diseases we can increase material wealth
we can like help people be happier more
fulfilled all of these sorts of things
foreign and then people are like oh well
no one is going to work but
people want
status people want drama people want new
things people want to create people want
to like feel useful
um people want to do all these things
and we're just gonna find new and
different ways to do them even in a
vastly better like unimaginably good
standard of living world